und dann kann liefern krieg losgegangen
und sie ist schon dort gesehen und
rettungsorganisation und dennoch als
plötzlich bogenberg km h
und ich bin extrem stephan katt schaffen
gemacht kann
wir haben uns ins herz getroffen
das ist ein weilchen eva und dort bin
ich als studentin im sommer gegangen und
nicht über auch dort ich bin ein kleiner
gruppe vor oder computer sind ist das
schon ziemlich kleines programm sehr und
sehen diese gruppe
wir haben uns in der ersten tage
[Musik]
es war schon ein problem von meinen
eltern weil sie sind nicht wirklich
religiös aber ein bisschen und meine
vater kommt von meinem ganze religiöse
familie und das war schwierig für sie am
anfang aber dann dann haben sie mich
besser kennengelernt und jetzt haben sie
es
besonders wichtig kultur kandidat
gefunden
sie macht das moma leckerbissen
israelischer hersteller das schlägt
natürlich so wenn wir das internet oder
das rentiert eher defensiv entscheid
machen wenn man so ein verhalten dass
ich jetzt die chancen und denkt jetzt
modern und bin weiß ich wie das ist der
stand seit zwei jahren
das ist denn das hätte viele
kostenfaktor slawen und das versprechen
dank wenn man in der name verliert
dennoch hat er spielt auf der
hintergrund denn ich habe mir das
natürlich dass sich aber eigentlich gar
nicht weggelegt kann was das jetzige 24
milliarden
und trotzdem ist natürlich am schluss
was user und ist dass man wirklich
gedacht hier andere kultur von artjom
mietet und den letztendlich doch eine
ganz andere lage wird vermehrt kaiser
das wird total in israel was überhaupt
nicht in tritt
sie habe eigentlich zu israel überhaupt
kapitän kann